democrats continue to point fingers at
joe manchin for dealing their far left
spending spree a much needed reality
check but ask yourself who do you think
knows west virginians better far left
democrats or senator manchin who
actually represents the state so fox
news digital went to the mountain state
for reaction take a look
i support joe manchin
120
absolutely supportive for him um not
backing down to
biden nothing in that bill was going to
help west virginia
and in fact it would cost us jobs
for which we of course would be paying
his taxpayer
i think it was the right thing to do
too much too much money going the wrong
direction i think he did a good choice
of denying it
so that is west virginia but of course
democrats and their allies in hollywood
can't help but launch us more smear
attacks against everyday america just
look at this disgusting tweet from bette
midler quote he sold us out he wants us
all to be just like his state of west
virginia poor illiterate and strung out
now midler later apologized for the post
but we all know how she really feels
even worse new york congressman jamal
boldman said this about the west
virginia senator
take a look
it's tremendously frustrating for me as
a black man in america because once
again it's an example of joe manchin as
a white man showing that he doesn't care
about black people he doesn't care about
latinos he doesn't care about immigrants
he doesn't care about women and he
doesn't care about the poor he is a
millionaire and he has the privilege to
kick the can down the road and not vote
for this bill while the people in my
district are suffering
here we go the same old tactics
here for reaction congressman byron
donalds and the author of all american
christmas fox news contributor sean
duffy gentlemen thank you all so much
for being with me today
uh congressman i'll start with you first
this is the same tactic but i would like
to educate uh the congressman about how
black folks and latinos were doing under
the trump administration
well look let me just tell you real
quickly whether you are black whether
you're hispanic it doesn't matter
whether you're jamal bowman or bette
midler they are dealing they don't
understand the economics that are going
on in our country if prices are rising
out of control that damages your ability
to live your life bette miller didn't
understand that because she's a very
wealthy actress and god bless her for
her success and my for my colleague from
new york he's forgotten that the money
that is spent by this administration and
the terrible coveted policies from the
two governors of new york now are what's
crushed the poor people of my former
home state of new york democrats need to
learn from their mistakes but they're
more committed to politics than they are
the economics of the american people you
know sean you know you listen to these
folks in west virginia they obviously
respect their senator telling
the american people what they how they
really feel about this legislation and
yet it doesn't seem like the democratic
democratic party cares i mean he's the
only democrat really there
well but the only one who cares about
west virginia is joe manchin and donald
trump got 68 of the vote right in west
virginia and here you have you know joe
manchin a democrat trying to run and win
in a state that is heavily republican
you got to be smart about your votes um
and so when you have bette midler you
know attacking west virginia west
virginia understands that buildback
better has a slew of green new deal
provisions in there that will kill
energy which kills west virginian jobs
and raises their taxes but if i could
just make one of the point on the race
issue i mean
whether you're socialist socialism or
communism massive debt or inflation it
doesn't care about the pigment of your
skin it affects all of us with the
different pigment on this panel the same
that's why if you go to venezuela or
cuba you can have people with more
pigment and they're getting destroyed by
these policies they destroy families and
economies equally and that's why good
smart republicans are standing up and
pushing back and thank god for joe
manchin who's saying listen this will
destroy the american dream i don't care
if you're poor or rich or black or white
or man or woman it's going to kill us
all so i'm going to say no to it good
for him you know congressman it wasn't
just the racial smear
it's about calling these voters
dumb strong god on drugs poor they don't
know any better so we have to rescue
them i mean this is what what they
really feel
about voters
listen the truth will always be that
people in their ordinary lives know far
more than liberal elites especially
those who might live on the coasts or in
washington d.c i will take what the
people of west virginia or florida or
missouri or texas say about government
overspending than somebody who has
basically lived at the top of american
life and doesn't understand the economic
realities on the ground that every
americans face and as a member of
congress i will tell you there's far too
many members who actually know the true
impacts of economic policy and how
washington has made that worse year over
year over year i'm staying with the
people yeah
sean you've been there you've been to
the halls of congress you've seen how
this thing operates every two years
congress is up um every uh uh six years
you got the senate what do you see
happening
so the best thing that happens is if if
republicans take over the house it's
very simple it's it's a stop of the
biden left-wing agenda the republicans
byron won't be able to do anything you
know pass any legislation because joe
biden will never sign it so the best
hope for america is we stop this
craziness and then if you're in the
senate and have a good uh 2024 you can
actually roll back some of these
policies but democrats understand that
if you get built back better into place
they know that it's almost impossible to
roll those policies back remember when
john mccain said no to obamacare and
they hailed him as a maverick isn't he a
wonderful republican who voted no
against
reform to obamacare where are all those
democrats right now saying you know what
i love joe manchin he's a maverick he's
going his own way they're not they don't
quite say that right now uh they hate
mavericks in the democrat party but they
love him in the republican party but
we're going to say no to the agenda and
hopefully have a great 20 20 22 and 2024
and get america back on track and as you
said
um is to to put america first america
first policies which will get us on
track to economic prosperity i i do find
it so comical that you're only a
maverick when you're on their side the
the moment you go to the other side
then you know you got to get out you got
to get out you got to get out the party
we don't want to be associated with you
you're evil you're racist i mean this
guy has been a democrat for years they
accept bernie
they accept crazy bernie the mansion has
to go i mean i just find it comical
gentlemen thank you so much congressman
sean thanks so much for coming on the
program tonight